[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode I
care less and you know for everyone when
they collect statues they have pieces
that they find to be quote unquote
Holy Grail pieces right and I'm a huge
Prince Namor fan Savage Submariner you
guys remember when I brought you another
video right from XM studios I believe he
was one of my first XM studio statues
this one right here this picture huge
tremendous base that baeza has an
octopus that statue is at least 50
pounds 60 pounds very heavy but there's
other statues of Prince Namor that um I
plan to acquire and I plan to bring to
you guys so this one is none other than
sideshows comic Samaritan and
it's it's very dead of me because I
always wanted this piece the size of the
statute is perfect the stance is perfect
and reminds me of the old cartoons they
used to come home used to come on and
remember I went into he's the first
character for Marvel he's the first
mutant he's a lot of firsts for Marvel
and he's about to debut in rumored in
the MCU in Black Panther 2 supposed to
be the rival of two kings Wakanda King
versus the king of Atlantis so in all
three statues that I want to bring one
is a Boleyn statute he has the red
underwear and the sideshow has the green
and the XM has him in his savage suit
where he's more of an antigenic villain
in that when he does you know team him
up to a doctor doing this statue was
acquired with a bunch of statues owned
you know I made a couple of trades and I
got this statue I was so happy I'm so
pleased to get it because I always
wanted it and I always thought that
would be one of the pillars of my statue
collecting so we know he's been on
numerous teams the avenges the
Illuminati the defenders x-men Namor is
a staple I believe at one point in time
he was debuting
but a featuring inside the comics of the
alpha flight because his cousin is on
the team so he's a huge staple in the
Marvel Universe very strong very
athletic one of the best heroes slash
villains in the MCU and in Marvel Comics
universe and I'm happy to have this one
so Diggle cream if you check out the
statue this is the exclusive one that
comes out it comes with two switch out
arms
well once which are armed and once for
child hand and I'm going to be this
displaying it with the Trident I think
it shows the ferocity you see that his
face he's ready to defend Atlantis and
it just just the Trident looks
incredible the lovely detail on it is
nice as you can see this is one of side
shows earlier artworks and the scope is
amazing it gives you the underwater feel
without it being any water that you can
see because a lot of statues would like
to convey the presence of water with
dueling water and this gives you the
sense of water without it being any
water around so I believe that did
brought that across and to convey that
very nice there's also the switch out
hand which shows his hand flared out
it's like he slid into the the polls
he's about to take into action action
dive swim you know go at you
it's a beautiful statute if you ever get
your hands on it I don't know if they
have an exclusive red underwear version
but I definitely will be bringing you
the Bowen with the red underwear so just
the part of the video where I'm gonna
ask you guys to like follow us subscribe
and also go to the Lords of gaming got
net you can get a ton I mean a ton of
opinion pieces news articles and reviews
you got a Lord addict he's right now
doing one of those card gaming reviews
at this moment as we speak and also we
have Laura kognito
with Aloha tea bonta's on the last word
that show is incredible
right now we have Borderlands 3 that's
an xbox free-to-play for the weekend
and you know that's eluded shooter
destiny tools going crazy
dead fix and ant them up right now so
with all this information and all this
news coverage there's only one place to
go that's lords of gaming got networks
also when you get a chance go to our
teespring store to check out some of the
new and worthwhile t-shirts that we were
you know like huh
our iron Lords tell it to t-shirts and
throw them in the bushes catch our
catchphrase so check that out also you
can catch old episodes of king of the
statues where you can see the first
statue I did would mean more to XM
studios 1 if you want to see in-depth
more about the character because I give
a largest synapsis about him his powers
and also the controversy with him versus
Aquaman so stick around watch to the end
of the video where you can see tons of
pictures and some more video
of this guy here without this guy here
talk see you next week and also remember
stay collecting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]